Okay, so we are a low audience. We're backstage. We're supposed to be doing a cold open, like a podcast right now. We did a cold open, we should have prepared. Right, we don't have anything ready to say. We're just doing mindless talking. We should maybe say, don't take flash photography or record the show. But introduce yourself, maybe you do that.
Okay, my name is Sean. Yeah, my name is Will. And you hold for the plot. Yeah, maybe you do that. Okay, my name is Sean. My name is Will. And you hold for the applause. Yeah, just on a different time. So, and I am Jason. Yeah. And did you say you were Will? No, but it was in the, my name is Will.
You do need to wake up just a little bit. I'm sorry. That's epic. That's epic. Okay. Ready? Here we go. Welcome to Smart Loss! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run Run! Run! Run! Run! Run Run! Run Run! Run! Run! Run! Run Run! Run! Run Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run Run! Run Run! Run Run! Run! Run! Run Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run Oh
Oh See Tracy from Wisconsin shirts look at these guys By the way tell him Tracy's here. Tracy's here. Yeah. So you're going to come out and say hi. Where is he? Come out and say hi.
Come on, just say hi. Tracy, come on. Guys, guys, guys, they're high. Look at this. Look at these guys. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this.
Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this.
Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. I think you're not regretting. Yes, I am not that you know, or maybe you do know or care. I'm from here. Yeah. Yeah. As Jason said, we're so glad you wanted to meet us. And we wanted to meet you. And the tour was the only way we could do it. So thank you.
Thank you. I just had to do it. It was just yelling at me. That was really hard. I was just happy before we came out. Why are you hitting me? It's really fun. No, no, no, no.
Here we go. This is a dream come true for you, right? Yes. You said you left Chicago many moons ago to drive to Los Angeles and you said, one day I'm going to come back here with my podcast. That's right. That's right.
You made it. That's everybody's dream. Right. But anyway, thank you for being here. We're going to sit on the couch now. All right, let's do it. All right. All right.
All right. All right. Well, I got to to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it.
Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it.
Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen University. What? The best school in the world. I'll tell you a little story. I don't know if I-
The school in the world is there, okay? Yeah, best school in the world. Just gotta talk. And I'm gonna tell you a little quick story about my experience there. One time I was so wasted freshman year. By the way, Waters and Towers, you know, Waters and Towers, okay. So Waters and Towers was great. It's the tallest year. By the way, water's in towers. You know, water's in towers. Okay.
Ah! So water's in towers is great. It's the tallest dorm building in the country, which is true. It is the tallest dorm building in the country. So if you went to a party on the outskirts and you got just fucking wasted, all you had to do, I remember coming home from parties
like this, I was like, oh my God, I don't know where I am. Oh, I just go there. I would walk to the waters and towers, because it was so easy. But one time, I think one of those nights, I was intoxicated, I went to a white hen, which now, remember white hen? Oh.
And I was... How was it compared to Portillo's? Well, white hen is 7-Eleven, basically. Okay, okay, got, sorry. Sorry. So, okay, got it. Sorry. Sorry. He's from Canada. So, I went in there and I was really drunk. I was with my friend Randy, who you guys just met.
And I was so drunk, I had no money, and I stole a turkey sandwich, right? And so, I went into the... Whoa, you shoplifted it? I shoplifted a turkey sandwich, because I was really hungry. Have you ever shoplifted? No.
I never have. All right, so I go in there and I'm like, oh, this is, you know, I'll be cool and I'll get to eat. So it was like, and I put a turkey sandwich in my bag. And literally, I go out and sit in front of the white hen and I'm just eating and I'm throwing the tomatoes at cars because I don't like the tomatoes. And all of a sudden, we're all laughing,
and all of a sudden, I see this cop's feet right in front of me. And I look up and I was like, oh, my God. And I got arrested. And so, yeah, I got arrested for stealing a turkey sandwich. And in the back seat, I was such an asshole. I was in the back seat, like, right around on the, like, so drunk and he goes, I go, hey, isn't there somebody getting murdered somewhere? Like, why are you arresting a guy that got in your mouth?
I'm running in your mouth. I'm so in Turkey. I'm running in my mouth. Turkey sandwich. Isn't there something more important? Anyway, so I go to the thing. It costs 100 bucks to get bailed out. My, I called one of my brothers.
They weren't around. And then this guy, Liam, who does the longest story in the world, Liam bailed me out. He was in the theater department. I didn't know him. And then, cut to like 15 years later. He gave me a hundred bucks, and I bailed. And then I paid back. This is Bateman Length Awful.
Yeah, yeah. So wait. So then 15 years later, I'm at Swinger's Unbeverly, which is a diner. Sure. Yeah. And he's my waiter, the guy which is a diner. Sure, yeah. And he's my waiter, the guy who bailed me out. What?
Isn't that good story, right? That's it. Yes. Yes. Wait, wait, wait, wait. Was that the only time you've ever, only time you've ever been arrested? Uh, yeah.
Hang on. No one has to think that long about what that pause usually means Should I say about the other three times I got arrested? No, no I didn't I never got arrested, but I do have a great masturbation story too if you want to hear that Well buckle up everybody But hang on second your next really red right here. You okay? It's just on this side. Yeah, because you fucking slept with me. What happened? No, it's not.
It's not. So when I was a kid, my dad's mom, my grandma on that side. So it's already a good story. Yeah. It's a... We're already off to a booming start. So she used to crochet all these animals. They were really cute.
She would give them to us. Like, they were like pre-shaped animals. Like, there was a dinosaur and a duck and like a mouse and a dog. And she would, you know, they had the form, but you crocheted around them. And so she gave us these things. And I used to cut out the whole of the dinosaurs
by mouth, and I used to fuck it. Wait. You know, there's a 5,000 people out here. Wait. Okay, so wait, so wait. Oh, good, there's more. Wait, did it matter what kind of dinosaur, like would you not get turned on by a Tyrannosaurus Rex,
but definitely a Bronx. One dinosaur. And the mouth was stuck open like that, so I looked at it, I was like, I'll just cut a whole hand, bye. Yeah. So then, so then I do this, right? And then I see all other kids coming over to play with and I'm like, ugh, God have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have You got to tell the story of my friend. Oh, because everybody does the masturbate, will. Not in the story of my friend.
Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend.
Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend.
Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. then I share them with you. And now you because you're my friends. Jason, have you been arrested? Oh, I know that's nice. So masturbation stories really bring people together? It does make that story cuter. Uh, Jason arrested. Arrested, development.
Great show. Oh. Oh, wait, wait. Sean, favorite scene go What was the name of his character? Joe I used to call it gob because I didn't know until like yesterday Well, yeah, I want to know I want to know worst arrested stories not the show rested from the cops I did I spent one night in jail
But in I think I may have even told some podcast. Monaco, yeah. I'm so old. I'm right, right. Yeah, it was in, yeah, it was in Monaco, and they gave me a pagemina, because I was cold. It's like real soft. Oh, and I did, I have to spend three innings
in Dodger Jail, because I got a little over served in about the sixth inning, and I had to cool off up in the Dodger Jail on the upper deck. Saul painted Dodger Blue, it's fun. And you're not allowed to see the end of the game. That's the punishment. And then they turn you loose. Canada seems like a reward. What about you, little hellcat?
Did you ever spend- Never arrested. I shoplifted once. I stole a bag of chips when they were 25 years old. What about you, little hellcat? Did you ever spend- Yeah, never arrested. And I did, I shoplanted once. I stole a bag of chips when they were like 25 cents. And I felt so bad the next day I went back into the convenience store. I was about 11, and I put a quarter on the counter
and walked out. True story. True story, that was it. Not as thrilling as mine, but that was the one. Oh, sorry. And then I fucked the bag of chips. LAUGHTER Are we back on track?
LAUGHTER And then I saw the other kids eating it and I was like, oh, hey, hey, hey, you know what? We're having fun. Well, you can't, you just can't eat one. All right. So. Wow. Well, okay.
So, we're gonna get to the guest. I'm super excited. I'm sure I get to get to the guest. I'm super excited. I'm super excited. I'm super excited. We really don't know. Just again, we really don't believe that you guys know. We really don't know who it is. We really don't know. Just again, we really don't believe that you guys know.
We really don't know who it is. We really don't know. And it's a whole tour. We've done a really good job of sequestering the guests, so we have no idea who it is. So I wrote my thing like Jason does. So this guy's amazing. One of his quotes is, I love this quote.
It doesn't matter how many times you fail, you only have to be right once, and then everybody says you're an overnight success. His dad used to say, which I love this quote, today is the youngest you'll ever be, live like it. How great is that? I love that. He went from banking to bartending to business software.
He's one of the pioneers of putting audio on the internet. He not only buys and sells companies. He's also immersed in the entertainment business as a co-owner of 29, 29 entertainment. He's not one of my favorite sharks. He is my favorite shark. It's Mark Cuban! What? Oh!
What? Let's go! Oh! Let's go! What? Oh! What's up? Wow!
Thank you for having me on that. Thank you so much. Shit! Thank you, man. Thank think we have me on there. Thank you so much. Shit. Are you ring new? Nice to have you on there. Hey, Sean. Oh, yeah, absolutely. You love me right there.
Oh, look at this. What the shoes. What the shoes. Let's start with the shoes. Start with the shoes. Start with the shoes. Are those shoes? Now are you a sneaker head?
I'm not. I'm not really. Are those significant though? Those are significant. Tell us about them. There's a guy who plays on our team named Luca Dodget. Sure. Yeah. Sure. And he, these are his shoes. Oh, I got it.
Designed for him. And so every now and then I pull them out. Right. Like you should. Like I should. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You got to make the big guy happy. And out. Right. Like you should. Like I should. Yeah. Yeah, you got to make the big guy happy. And they're great.
And they match. Yeah. Look at you. That's great. Look at me. Sharp suit. Wow. And by the way, we were going to do, fly you out like real nice,
you know, because you were so nice to come on. He's like, I'll fly myself. Yeah. Not literally. Not literally. Yeah, I've been told. But, you know, it was pretty nice. But, I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that,
but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that,
but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say and that's why. So, so, so, so, how do you buy a basketball team? You write a big mother fucking check, that's what you do.
But they're not just sitting around, right? I mean, how long were you sort of clocking it and see, there might be an opportunity and like, how do you get a heads up on that? So, this was like 22 years ago, 99, 2000 season. I was a season ticket holder in the Mav's Raffle. Yeah. And I just made a lot of money. Yeah.
And so I go to the game and I'm like, by the way. By the way, here's a thing. That's good luck. I know. Yeah. But wait, here's the thing. It's like, we're all taught to not say things like that. Because we're like, you shouldn't like, slon it.
But I love that you do. You make a luckiest motherfucker in the entire world. I am proud to be your friend. You have consistently been pretty straight up and honest, you don't posture about it. You always say it as it is. That is great. I love that, yeah.
No, keep going. OK, so you got dirty, still wear a white badge. So you made it happen to make a ton of money. You're at the game. And it's the start of the season. And I'm there with you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that.
So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that.
So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on Right. Just like that? Just like that.
And what do you call to find out if they're even for sale? The guy. I mean, no. You call the guy? The guy. No. The owner was a guy named Ross Pro Jr. And didn't know or care anything about basketball.
Wait, Ross Pro Jr.? Yeah. That was my first vote at 18. I voted for Ross Pro. Really? I really did. Yeah. I was so excited.
Oh, because I... Oh, you're the one. I was a big... I was a huge Dana Carvey fan. So I was like, let's do it. I have one Ross Pro story. I have one Ross Pro senior story. So my very first company after I got fired, I started this company, Micro Solutions, and the big deal. Yeah, we're talking about that too. And the big deal was, we had this big deal. That's what we do with Sean too.
Cool. Look at my story. And so I got a chance to do business with them. So we had a chance to do business with them. So we had this big deal. That's what we do with Sean too. Cool. That looks like my story. Yeah. And so I got a chance to do business with them. So he was like the big thing in Dallas. And I'm like 24 years old.
And so I get to go into this office. He's got the original Magna Carta. Wow. He's got the statue for Iwo Jima right there in his office. This is Ross Perot Jr. or senior? Senior, senior. The scariest moment of my life literally was walking down that hall hoping I did not destroy American history.
Right. Because there he was. No, leave that to other people. The other people, right. So of course you tried to stop that too. You tried to help out with that, too. Yeah, it did go so well the first time. But anyways, long story, sorry, I get to him, and I say, hi, Mr. Cuban, I'm Ross Pro.
No. Really? Oh, no. When you gave away your position, all your leverage was gone in that moment. Yeah, because a 24-year-old just started, has a ton of leverage. Yeah, so he laughed.
Wait, you were 24? Wait, when you were like, when you were almost 24 right now. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no 24-year-old just started as a ton of leverage, yeah, so he laughed. Wait, you were 24? 24, right? When you were almost 24, right now. No, no, no, no, no, no. Oh, when you did that. No, no, no.
When you met, when you met with senior. Yeah, that's right. I met with senior first time. So when I bought the team, right? So I got to meet junior. And literally from start to finish was about three weeks. Wow. Yeah.
So he was an eager seller. He was an eager seller. And I, you know, he thought I was going to be a negotiation. And so when I sold, this was right in the middle of the internet stock boom, right? So literally, every day, the stock that I got from my company, from an old company called Yahoo, would go up $20. So it was like, wait, is Yahoo still around?
Not really, no. Yeah, so you still look look, it's printed everywhere. It's like $5.7 billion. That's what they gave you. Well, they gave it to us and stock, and I got a third of that. OK, can I... Yeah.
We deal with that third shit all the time. Oh, yeah, believe me. Uh, fuck. We just did it with cake from Portillo's. Yeah. So we actually did. We actually did. I don't mean to embarrass you, but I'm sure this is probably
all public. What did you pay for the team and what is it worth now? So I paid $285 million. I love that you just see that. OK. Yeah. It's probably like a lie. It's probably a lie.
No, but it's unbelievable. Here's why. And so you can go on. Well, it's fine with me. We all did a ton of co-op before we came out here. I know. Can you tell it's not obvious? Wait, so you paid how much?
$285 million. That's crazy. And now it's worth, and I'm not $3 billion, $2.5 billion. Wow. It's only worth that if you're going to sell it, right? I have no plans. But all the teams have gone up exponentially bunch. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So it's like any kind of commodity, any kind of thing.
It's like you invest in it like a house or whatever. And it's always kind of like a house. Like if you love your house, right? You bought the house and it's going up in value. If you bought a house for $235 million, it goes up because people love that sport. Yeah, yeah. So we've been fortunate and basketball's been very, love that the sport. Yeah, that, yeah. So, you know, we've been fortunate,
and basketball has been very, very good to me. Yeah. And so. That's crazy. So you were always in the sports, or specifically basketball? No, I've been. Yeah, not very well, but I've been a basketball junkie since I've been five years old. Are you disciplined about not sort of stepping on the toes
of the way in which the team is run, or do they want that? No, no. I think $280 million. $280 million. $280 million for that motherfucker. I get to do what I want. is sort of stepping on the toes of the way in which the team is run or do they want that? $25 million for that motherfucker. I get to do what I want. So, you're on the floor for a lot of games, if not all of them. In the middle of the game, will you go over and say to the head coach, hey man, you got to sit that guy down or I want him in the game. No, that I want to.
That's where I draw the line. Now I might go to the referees and say what the fuck was that? But you are like famously, are you not the most fine, by far? Yeah, by far. Yeah, I love how proud you are of that.
But why? Because they get it wrong all the time. Who the fuck sets except that? So you get fine, you get fine by the referees. No, no, they wish, no, by the league, by the NBA. We're talking to the referees. No, no, they wish no by the league by the NBA We're talking for talking to the referees during the game more for saying something publicly after the game after the game I said your referee look. I'm sorry. I could have you killed That's what I would do if I if I was in your position. I would just look at I can go like this one time
I went like this one time to a rapper. I got fine for that, yeah. Oh my God. That's crazy. Like I can't believe you own a team. OK. So it's just like, oh, and I have new pair of shoes and I own this team.
OK. But wait, talk about microsolutions because what is it? And how did you start? I'm, say what you were going to say before. I was going to say, Sean was talking about his microsolutions earlier in Intro. Yeah, but I invested a lot of time in it and it grew and grew. So please.
So it was a grow or not a show or? That's it. No, it's a show or. So, no, so talking about microsolutions because, so I got fired from a show. No, it's a show. So, no, so talking about microstaticias, because, so I got fired from a job, right? So I was working in a job selling software and I had this deal, so step back. At the time, when I moved to Dallas
from Indiana University, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, So after I went from IU down to Dallas, the only place I could live because I had no money. And so I lived in a shithole with five roommates. And literally, I didn't have a bathroom. I didn't have a room. I just had not even a closet. I just have a place that I just would sleep on, right? Like what year is this sort of? This is 1982.
OK. Yeah. Way back when when I was six. Yeah. So six. Yeah, yeah. And so I got a job at night working as a bartender slash bar back and then during the day I got a job working as a software company. So I'm starving, right, and living in the shithole and I have a chance to close this big deal,
right, and I'm going to get a $1,500 commission. I get to move out of the shithole. And so I go to my boss, you boss, normally I'm supposed to wipe down the windows and sweep the floor and open up the store. And I'm like, how Jason grew up, yeah. Really rough. Superly rough, yeah. Just that hot.
Fast food to fast food to fast food. And so I'm like, to my boss, a guy named Michael Humbecky, in case you're in into him. And so I'm like, I need to go pick up this check. And he goes, no, you have to open the store. And so I make the executive decision to go pick up the check. Yeah. Thinking if I hand him a $15,000 check,
I got my $15,000 commission there, he'd be happy. Fires my ass. Wow. Fires me on the spot. And so that now I'm left with nothing. And I figured, OK, I'm a lousy employee. So I'm going to go start this company. I was in the PC business, so I called it micro-solutions
and started with a first customer, $500, grew that to 80 employees, $30 some million in sales, and sold it to H&R Block. And was this based on something that you studied, did you study computers or business or anything? No, no, I like cheated in my computer class in Indiana. So who's yours, baby? Wait, say again, how old were you again?
I was 24. 24, and what age was that when you were like, wait a minute, this is kind of cool, I can buy and sell companies and all that? No, it's just like, I got fired, and it was like, I had to do something, I realized I was a bad employee, but in the nine months I was there, I learned a lot about software. And not a lot of people knew much about software.
So I was able to go company to company to company and just slowly but surely hired one person, then two person, then 10 till we get up to about 80 people. And then it took seven years without a vacation. So it wasn't like overnight, sold it, but a lifetime passed on American Airlines and partied like a rockstar. Oh my God.
And we will be right back. Smartlis is supported by NetSuite by Oracle. If your business earns millions or tens of millions of revenue, stop what you're doing and take a listen because NetSuite by Oracle is just rolled out the best offer we have ever seen. NetSuite gives you the visibility and control you need to make better decisions faster. And for the first time in NetSuite's 25 years as the number one cloud financial system, you can defer payments of a full NetSuite implementation for six months. There's no payment and no interest for six months. And you can take advantage of this special financing offer today. Net suite is number one because they give your business
everything you need in real time all in one place to reduce manual processes, boost efficiency, build forecast and increase productivity across every department. It just sounds like it makes a lot of sense listener, right? I mean? You can agree with that, can't you? You're so agreeable. Thank you. More than 36,000 companies have already upgraded to NetSuite gaining visibility and control over their financials, inventory, HR, e-commerce, and more.
So if you've been sizing NetSuite up to make the switch, then you know this deal is unprecedented. No interest, no payments. Take advantage of this special financing offer at NetSuite Up to make the switch, then you know this deal is unprecedented. No interest, no payments. Take advantage of this special financing offer at netsuite.com slash smartless netsuite.com slash smartless to get the visibility and control you need to weather any storm netsuite.com slash smartless smartless smartless sponsored by ADT. ABT self setup features everything from motion sensors to Google Nest cams with no long-term contracts.
Easy install the ADT self setup security system at your convenience. No heavy duty tools are needed. And if you need help, ADT can provide virtual assistance along the way. ADT self-startup grows, moves, and adapts as your needs change. You can add more products at any time and your system easily moves wherever life takes you. It also features nest cams that can tell the difference between a person, an animal, a vehicle, or with the Nest Doorbell even a package. Plus, when every second counts, you can trust ADT's 24-7 professional monitoring.
You can view video of an alarm event and verify or cancel an alarm with just a tap. When the most trusted name and home security adds the intelligence of Google, you've got a home with no worries. So go to ADT.com today or call 1-800-ADT-ASAP, Google, Nest Cam, Nest Doorbell, and Nest Aware are trademarks of Google LLC. This episode is brought to you in part by 8 sleep. Hey, did you know that temperature is one of the most important factors in improving your sleep quality?
Did you know that? Well, I'm going to fill you in here. While traditional mattresses trap heat throughout the night's science has shown that your body temperature actually needs to drop in the early and middle part of your sleep and rise in the morning so that you can fall asleep fast and get more deep sleep. The pod cover by eight sleep fits on any bed like a fitted sheet
and will improve your sleep by automatically adjusting the temperature on each side of the bed based on you and your partner's individual needs. You know, me and my wife, we've got different needs and a lot of things in life, not the least of which is sleep temperature. You know, sometimes I'm all heated up about one thing and other times she's
well, you know, and I, it's just who falls asleep at the same temperature as your partner? You ever thought about that? Probably no one. So, you know, this is saving mankind, simply put. While temperature is the biggest game changer, the pod cover has other amazing features. Listen up, for example, thanks to the pod's sleep and health tracking, you can wake up to a personalized sleep report for you each morning that offers insights on how certain behaviors like late night exercise or caffeine impact your sleep and overall health.
caffeine impact your sleep and overall health. So let's invest in the rest you deserve with the 8-Sleep Pod. Go to 8-Sleep.com slash smartless and save $150 on the pod cover by 8-Sleep. That's the best offer you'll find, but you must visit 8-Sleep.com slash smartless for $150 off. 8-Sleep currently ships within the USA, Canada, the UK select countries in the EU and Australia. And now back to the show. Would you say that the thing that is more important
to your success is your knowledge of the field or your ability to identify people that are good to work in other words, your people skills or your knowledge of your profession. I think it's that I really, I'm a quick learner, I'm a quick study, right? So when I go into new technologies, I can pick stuff up really fast. And so I'm able to, you say, okay, that's what's next. And so find an angle, what's coming next. Yeah, how do you know that?
Like, to me it just makes sense. Like, you know, when I started microsolutions, instead of just buying one PC, I thought people are gonna connect them together. And most people are like, no, that's not to a later. And then they connect them together, that was my thing, and then wrote software for it, taught myself to write software and built it up.
And then in the mid 90s, you know, a buddy of mine came to me and said, there's got to be a way we can listen to Indiana basketball over this new thing called the Internet. And I was like, okay, I'll figure it out. And then you created audio on the Internet. It was called audio net. It was the first streaming company on the Internet. And why? Because I'm very young. So the Internet didn't have audio at first and you kind of created that with this. No, people thought I was a moron.
Yeah, there was like a player. I remember there was like an audio player that you had to have a play-out. Yeah, in order to stream back in the early days, right? You had to have a PC with a modem, download this thing called a TCP IP client, download a client software from your ISP, then download another real, an audio player, right?
And then you had to go to a website and click on a file, and that file would open up, and then you hope it would play. We had a half hour. But then you're all set. But then you're all set, right? But we were the first to do it. But like, one of our best, one of the things that helped us the most, like if you were anywhere outside the city of Chicago,
the only way to listen to the Cubs games during the afternoon was on audio and that right so we crushed it because Cubs fans all over the world would go there click on this thing and go through all the hassle you know but that started the whole streaming industry and then that just you know like so you're doing your crazy business did you have an idea when you were whatever 24 and back then that you did you have this dream? I'm gonna be a fucking business Titan. I'm gonna do this. Did you did that was that a possibility? No, no, you know like my doing micro solutions. I remember vividly Finally getting a bed laying there hung over gone. Oh my god. We've been in business three months
Oh my god. We've been in business four months. Oh my God, we've been in business five months, right? Just being terrified that it went last. So it was just piece by piece that it just sort of... Just crying, you just crying, crying, crying. What are you gonna hope you would become? When did you study in school? I took a business, yeah. So you just hope to find a business,
didn't matter what it was. I knew I'd be an entrepreneur, right? Cause I'd start a business as my entire life little things. But where did that come from? Like, as a kid, where your parents run it? Like, see, I think what's fascinating about you and people like you is like, we're on the outside going, how do this guy do that?
Like, we're like, is there steps I could take to maybe be like Mark Cuban? Like, where did I fucking go wrong? You know what I mean? Yeah, I mean. I could tell you. I mean, opening with a masturbation story. I also wanna know, like, what is that moment?
Do you, you probably do, and tell us if you do. Remember the moment that you were, you first realized, or the moment you were first, a billionaire. Well, fuck yeah, a remover. So, yeah, so. I was like, that insects for the first time, right? Yeah, yeah.
You remember it every bit of it. All time, right? Yeah, yeah. You remember every bit of it. All right, Sean? Yes, Sean. No, because broadcast.com went public. And we had this big IPO, and the stock just kept on going up. And I knew exactly what the price had to be in order for me to become a billionaire. And so on the OPCs, you get it F5 to refresh your Yahoo Finance.
You know, left five, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, and then, and it was like right when the market opened in Dallas at 830. And so I'm just sitting there basically mostly naked and I didn't live at home, right by myself. Getting that F5. Yeah. But that's, you're just by yourself at home when you're fucking home computer going,
am I a billionaire? Yes, and then I do my little billionaire dance, right? I was just like, hey! Would you, would you do to get what you call first? No, what's that? Did you call? No, because I knew, you know, it might only be a second, right? Right, right, right.
Just like Sean's story. Oh my god. Sean. That's good. What my God. Sean. That's good. What do you guys do this? Yeah, OK, great. Well, I think everybody here has had the fantasy of like,
what if I won the lottery? If I became, what's my fantasy big thing to buy? What was it? Basketball team. Yeah, there you go. Was it really? Yeah. There we go. Was it really? It wasn't like I dreamed about it.
But I mean, what was the first big check? Maybe it was 20 grand or 100 grand or something. Well, when I saw my first company, Micro Solutions, I literally, my buddies and I went out and just got shit-faced at an old school Italian restaurant. They had the phones that they would bring to you. And so I was trash. And they're like, what do you want? I'm like not into cars, not into, I have a house.
I want a lifetime pass in American Airlines. So I can just go anywhere, anytime, anyhow. Really? And so I traveled enough that I remember the number and I'd call them up and I'm like, do you guys sell lifetime passes? And they were like, yes, let me connect you to the Air Pass Department.
I'm like, get the fuck out of here, right? And I bought one and it ended up being $250,000, and I got to fly me and anybody else that I wanted, anywhere American Airlines flies for the rest of my life. As often as you want. As often as I want. No way. Wait, just for a flat.
I gave it to my dad who unfortunately passed away a few years ago, and then I gave it to a friend who uses it So it was a $250,000 flat fee no more money ever for the rest of your life And you can fly you plus one anywhere you want all the time you want until you first class They still have no way they still have that no they got rid of them because there were a couple guys You could spend that in that yeah, I also got my American Airlines miles, right? So there'd be guys you just fly back and forth just to get their miles, and that was just like, too much.
Wow. But it was a lot of fun. Yeah. Where did you go to the Olympics? Let's go to Moscow. Let's go to Vegas. As long as you got delays and you got peanuts and the thing. Oh, great.
We're going to find the thing that's a bummer about it. Where did, at what point did you want to go into a filmmaking television stuff and start your studio? That was more because of my partner Todd. Todd and I were partners for Todd Wanger and I were partners in broadcast.com. And he wanted to do a lot of vertically integrated stuff. And so after I sold broadcast, we also started the first all high definition TV network HD net.
And so, and then we bought landmark theaters. So, I started, we started HD net and we wanted to do day and day to everything, right? And this was, what is it? Day and day meeting, we released a movie on HD net and in theaters and landmark theaters and we released the DVD and we released it online. Oh, at the same time. Right. Right.
Which now is a big deal, right? That they're trying to do with HBO Max. And so we started doing that. And probably 2003. We started doing little things. In 2003, I get an email from a guy named Alex Gibney. And he's like, I've got this footage from this company called Enron. And I email him back.
Oh, yeah, yeah. And I'm like, do you own the exclusive rights to it? Yeah. Can you put it in a move in your documentary you want to do? Yeah. What's the budget for this movie Enron that you want to do? And he goes $70,000 or $70,000. I'm like, OK, let's do it.
12 minutes, I greenlit this movie. Yeah. So it turns out being Enron the smartest guys in the room, a documentary right? Yeah,000. I'm like, okay, let's do it. 12 minutes, I agree, let this movie. So it turns out being Enron the smartest guys in the room at Documentary Rights. It gets nominated for an Academy Award. At the time, it was top 10 grossing documentary of all time. I'm thinking this movie shit is easy, right?
Then... Yeah, this isn't gonna be a money pit at all. No, at all, right? Then my partner Todd Wagner brings to me a deal with George Clooney. It's going to be a black and white movie about the 50s with Roy Cohen and the McCarthy hearings, right? Good luck with that guy. Right, and it was going to be called Good Night and Good Luck.
Yeah, such a good movie. Such a good movie. Such a good, it gets nominated for Six Academy Awards. My second movie on the, there's shit that's still easy, right? And even better yet, we had, because we got nominated, we had a party at, oh, what's the place on Hollywood? Anyways, one of the old school Italian restaurants. Dentanos. Dentanos. Yeah, right? And I'm doing a body shot off of Cindy Crawford.
And I'm there going, shot off of Cindy Crawford. And I'm there going, this movie shit's great. This movie shit's great. You haven't heard of a movie we've done since, right? Right. We've done little things. We have a company. We sold, 29.29 still does some stuff.
And we sold some of the other stuff. And we sold landmark theaters. And we still have magnolia pictures to distribute stuff. Yeah, let me do great, tell me something that you thought for sure was going to succeed and you're like, oh God, that did not work at all. Nothing. No.
Wow. Excellent. Really? No, so many things. Like what's the biggest mistake you made early on in your career that you would like, the biggest thing you would give advice to somebody would like, watch out for this.
I know you're doing great here, but really watch out for this person or this thing or this idea. Yeah, I think, you know, one of the lessons I learned is I would just hire fast, right? Because I'm a sales person at heart. And I would just like, okay, I'm selling myself on hiring this person.
And I've learned you got a higher slow in fire fast. So I would make a lot of mistakes in hiring that cost me money. Why? Because just you interview too many people who really want to find out the right fit? Yeah, where I would not interview enough. Right. And so I would just be like, OK, come on, I'll make it work.
I would be so good person. Yeah, yeah. I would be so arrogant that I thought, OK, I can make this work no matter what. Or I'd be so arrogant about how much business I know. I look at a business and go, OK, you're going to do this wrong, this wrong, this wrong. And yeah, I know Uber is going to be good.
And I know you're going gonna do really well with Uber, but you need to give me a better valuation. And the guy's like, no. And so I missed out on Uber, you know? What do you think is your, seems like you've really checked a lot of boxes and had a lot of success, you're not an old guy. Like what are you thinking about would be
a really significant challenge for you that actually scares you going forward? Well like right now we're taking on the pharmacy companies. Yes, I was gonna ask you about this. Yeah This is Do you guys not have you heard about what he's doing? I haven't told me it's amazing. So it's called cost plus Plus so Cost plus drugs.
Drugs.com. And so basically what we've done, the pharmacy industry is really distorted. They have these things called pharmacy benefit managers that are kind of like bouncers at clubs. They want to get paid in order for the pharmaceutical companies to provide their drugs to insurance companies who then approve them for doctors.
And so we said, we're going to create our own pharmacy benefit manager, but we're not going to make it convoluted. We're not going to ask for rebates like all the other ones do. Because of that, we can sell direct to consumers at our cost plus 15%. Give us an example of... I can't even pronounce all of these, but it will take something...
Insulin, yeah. No, we don't have insulin yet. We're working on the outskirts. Take that back. Yeah. Yeah. We're working on the LK. Take that back. Yeah. Yeah. We're working on it. But if you go to CosplusDrucks.com,
you can see exactly what our cost are. And so there's drugs that will sell for $6 that everybody else is selling for $400. That's amazing. How is it? And when do you think? I just think that's incredible. CosplusDrucks.com.
Now, are you doing this now? Is this a business for you? Is there a profit in here for you somewhere? So everything we're transparent about everything. So we're not trying to make as much money as possible. It's a public benefit corporation, so it's different in what we're allowed to do, too. But we reinvest, so the market of 15%,
we reinvest so that we're building a manufacturing facility in Dallas so we can push down the price of drugs. So our goal, we're starting off with 100 drugs two weeks ago and our goal by the end of the year is to have 2,000 drugs and our bigger goal is, now we're so used to seeing prices of drugs who will up, up, up, up, up, right? Every week or two, we wanna be able to post
a reduction in price of the drugs that we have, right? How are you able to access these drugs at a wholesale price, though? Because we go right to the main factories. Just asking again, because they didn't hear. Oh, sorry, how are you able to access these drugs at a wholesale price, though? Because we go right to the main factories. What were the factories asking again, because they didn't hear it. Oh, sorry. How are you able to access these drugs at a wholesale price? We'll go to the manufacturers or we'll make them ourselves. And the ones we go to the manufacturers, they have to sell them basically, you know, just
a little bit more than they sell to everybody else. Yeah. But everybody else asks for rebates from them, which in turn, jacks up the price. We don't ask for any of those rebates. We don't fuck around with the price. It is just cost plus 15%. $3 filfee and $5 for shipping. Well, if you guys thought about making
any of the fun drugs? Yeah. I mean, you just like a whole fun page. You don't even mean over like... Yeah, you just put a slash molly and I'm not saying it. Well, you, my husband, Scottie, he's got diabetes since he's 17 years old. It's hilarious.
But I, whenever I introduce him, I go, this is my husband, Scottie, he's gonna die from diabetes. No, will that be on that list, insulin or...? So, to do insulin, it's this all convoluted thing where you've got to create something called a biosimilar. So it's a mess. It's hard. And so we're looking at it, but it takes close to four years. And so we're looking at starting that process.
And what are some of the, how do you determine what companies you want to invest in or where you want to put your money? You know, it really depends. Like on Shark Tank, Friday nights on ABC, APM, BST, or SMPM Central. Yeah, I can't wait to get it right into it
no shark tank is part t v right so you're not making normal business decisions but normally it's like is it differentiated you know is there a reason for me to buy it like we started cost plus drugs dot com there's no marketing we're not spending any money on on marketing or advertising because everybody wants cheaper prices for drugs Yeah, right? And so it really depends on what the product is and if there's if it's differentiated
It's something people obviously need and the person who creates it is Smart then I typically try to invest so you're talking to a dumbass, right guys Confirmed confirmed so right guys. Confirmed? Confirmed. So, somebody comes on Shark Tank. What they do is they pitch you an idea and you decide whether that's a great idea and if it's a better idea than the other two people that pitched, they get what? Funding for their idea? Yeah. Yeah, I'm so sorry man. Yeah. You never watch the show, Ed. I I watched Dodgers and that's it. That's okay. Now, do you obviously own a piece of that company if it takes off?
Well, if I invest in money, yes, I ask for a piece of the company. Yeah, I do. You own the whole thing? My God. Or like what's never won on the old whole thing? Because you want the entrepreneur, the person who started it, right to be successful and make money too. What's the percentage that they get?
Typically, they'll keep 80% of it now. I'll just take care of it now just take a look at what's dark tank the rest of you believe it's right i have a miss so so wait let's get right into it because i've eight hundred questions okay wait a minute just hang on let's say all right so should we have commercial commercial wait uh... okay so the same question about your business.
What is the criteria you look for on Shark Tank when somebody comes in and pitches something? What is it? Spiked ball. That's the one I fucked up on. Thank you very much. What is it? No, spike ball.
Spiked ball. Have you ever seen kids on the beach playing? Yes, yes, right. So they came on Shark Tank and they're like, Mark, we want you to be an investor. They want you, they want me to be the commissioner of their spikeball league. I'm like, I don't want to be a commissioner of the spikeball league. Yeah.
You know, so I didn't do the deal. Now every beach, everywhere. You go, you know, down here on the beach. And that's all you see anywhere. What spikeball is that like volleyball? Guys, I don't fucking know it. Guys, I don't fucking do it. They're fucking building you, dude. I don't know what it is either.
Black boys, they have like this little trampoline. There's little trampoline thing. You stand around with some friends and you hit this ball and you bounce it off the thing, right? Oh, never mind. And you all bounce off. And just very kind of competitive and it's good exercise. And you get it up. I didn't need you to get it up.
Yeah. That sounds fun. But I wouldn't hear that idea and go, that's a billion dollar idea. Well, I knew kids would like it, right? But sometimes you just want to just invest. You don't want to be the commissioner. Right.
You know, and so. So that was a part of the deal. That was part of the deal. Yeah, and I don't want to do that part of it. Yeah, you're busy. I'm busy. Yeah, so but do you have a, do you have a, like anytime you, you, you join a company or invest in a company office
shark tank, do you have then a company yourself, like the people working a office somewhere that handles that? We used to work in an office now, but yeah, I have people who help me. Yeah, and so do you? Yeah, he's got a staff, Sean. You got a staff, Sean. I think he does it all himself.
No, but, but. And I was going to make another joke for your first of an obnoxious. But I'm not going to. Fine. Wait, so, but when you, it has, is there, has there ever been a time when the cameras are over and they walk out and they're like,
oh my god, I made a deal with Mark Cuban and you're done taping the show and then you and the deal falls through. Oh yeah, yeah. When do I use that? So sometimes they'll just lie their asses off, right? Because they get nervous, right? They may take. They lie, right?
You know, I've got $1 million in sales and then you go, we get to do due diligence afterwards because we know people might not quite tell the truth. And then you go to look and they have 100,000 in sales, or 20,000 in sales, and they hope to have a million. You know, where my widget costs a dollar and it costs $10. So yeah, there's times when it doesn't close. Do you mind if I pitch you a product right now?
Let's go. Okay. All right. All right. Do you want to do it? Do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we,
do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do Do will you get up there come on do will and I get us get I'm gonna do it actually I'm gonna bring out my husband Scotty so I do it in the truth fashion Stand up he's gonna be dead soon Yeah, come closer. Don't get too attached to him. I know. I'm going to die from diabetes. Yeah. Oh, my God. Oh, my God. All right, so here we go. Do you guys believe in Scotty's here?
Woo! Oh, my God. OK. OK, so this isn't the true style of Shark Tank. Wait, I thought you were pitching to me. Get your ass over there. I can't because then they'll say you're actually OK. Wait, I thought you're pitching to me. Get your ass over there. I can't because then they'll see you're actually okay. Oh, man, you're gonna be okay.
So here we go. Oh, okay. Oh, okay. Oh, okay. Oh, okay. Okay, shh. Shh, shh, shh. Shut the fuck up. Shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, sh, shh, sh, sh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, sh, shh, shh, shh And we're from Hollywood, California.
And we're looking for $2 million for 2% of our company, Doggy Defense. When you're loading the dishwasher, does your dog come out and clean the plates before the dishwasher does? R's does, which gives us pause for concern. Oh, God. Oh, boy. Let me tell you a little tale. We came up with a fence barrier that goes around your dishwasher door
that detours your dog from accessing the dishes. And with that defense up, our dog is no longer barking up the wrong tree. So sharks, don't leave your dishes in a rough state. Who wants to be the first one to join our pack? Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Okay.
Shhh! Yeah. Now for the uninitiated, was that similar to the way it goes down? Oh, yeah! Yeah. Otherwise, that was really weird. No, no! No, no. You got to go.
You got to go. The people that come on, God bless them, they're all lovely. They're all trying hard. They're really awkward and weird. They don't know how to, you know, they're obviously being coached and written and it's very practice. When is there a, where's the swimming part? When do you get in the water?
Right at the beginning, right? I want to hear what you think of the idea. Knowing that sound. Yeah. $6 million. I'm saying, you right? I want to hear what you think of the idea. What do you think of the idea? $200. I'm saying, right? So when you're at US dollars, hey, so when you pull the dishwasher down and you're doing it,
and the don't touch the shots, yeah, we get it. I got it. I got it. OK. I thought I'd get it. I think it's a perfect deal for Mr. Wonderful. OK. No ask for royalty.
Yeah, royalty. I love it. I just wanted to hear you once say, I'm out. but I think it's a perfect deal for Mr. Wonderful. Oh, okay. No ask for royalty. Yeah, royalty. I love it. I just wanted to hear you once say, I'm out. That's right. Oh. We'll be right back. SmartLess is supported by Rocket Money. Now, this company seems to make a whole lot of sense to me.
So most people think they're spending $80 on the subscriptions when in reality the number is closer to 200. When you're signed up for so many things like streaming services you use to watch one show or free trials for delivery, you don't use, it's so easy to lose track of what you're paying for. With rocket money, you can easily cancel the ones you don't want with just the press of one button. No more long hold times or annoying emails with customer service.
Rocket money does all the work for you. Rocket money can even negotiate to lower your bills for you. Yeah, buy up to like 20%. All you have to do is take a picture of your bill and rocket money takes care of the rest. I mean, does that not make sense? Does that not sound like a great function and feature of a company? Listen, stop wasting money on things you don't use, all right? Cancel your unwanted subscriptions.
Manage your money the easy way. Go to rocketmoney.com slash smartless. That's rocketmoney.com slash smartless. Rocketmoney.com slash Smartless. That's rocketMoney.com slash Smartless. RocketMoney.com slash Smartless, I said. Smartless is supported by Airbnb. Smartless listener, have you ever stayed in an Airbnb and thought to yourself, hey, you know what this actually seems pretty doable?
Maybe my place could be an Airbnb. Well, maybe it really could be. It could be as simple as starting with a spare room or your whole place when you're away. You can be sitting on an Airbnb. You don't even know it. You know, like let's say you got a vacation plan for the summer. And while you're away, there's some big sports event that's coming into your city, use your house, you know, just like put it up,
see what you get. If you don't get a price that you like, you take it off. I mean, I don't know, this seems to make sense to me, but you know best. You do what's right for you, unrenting my house. Whether you could use a little extra money to cover some bills or for something, or a little more fun, your home or spare room
might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at Airbnb.com slash host. Our deep, deep sincere and heartfelt thanks to Zippercrooter for their support gang. Let me tell you a little bit about Zippercrooter, okay? If you're hiring, you know that it's incredibly hard to attract top talent, and with the current labor market conditions, well, it's even harder than ever. That's why you want a partner who gets it. Zippercrooter.
Zippercrooter knows how tough it is right now, but they've figured out solutions for the problems that you're facing. See for yourself. Right now, you can try them for free at zippercruder.com slash smartless. Zippercruder is ready to tackle your recruiting challenges. To teach more of the right people, Zippercruder, post your job to 100 plus job sites. Need to hire ASAP? Zippercruder smart technology finds great matches for your job sooner. Want first dibs on talent? Zippercrooter lets you invite the most qualified people to apply to your job. Plus Zippercrooter's pricing is straightforward. No surprise costs.
Team up with a hiring partner who understands what you need. Zippercrooter, four out of five employers who post on Zippercrooter, get a quality candidate within the first day. Just go to this exclusive web address to try Zippercrooter for free. Zippercrooter.com slash smartless. Again, that's zippercrooter.com slash smartlews. Zippercrooter, the smartest way to hire. the smartest way to hire. And now, back to the show. Now, what's to stop? What's to stop anybody watching the show when you guys don't take something
for somebody to steal Sean and Scott out of the time? Yeah, it really happens all the time. Like if we don't make a deal, and sometimes even when we do, there'll be somebody and investor out there watching the show and do a quicker. And we'll just get a hold of them and say, I'll offer you more money.
Oh really? And when I'm fine with that, right? It helps the entrepreneurs and it's great for them. But you're saying does anybody see the idea on TV and then steal it? And steal it, yeah. Oh no, and then do the same thing themselves. Correct.
Oh yeah, typically not because it's hard to do, right? Look, or is there enough of a delay on airing the show that you guys typically have your business done before? And we can, yeah, we can, but it's hard to see. I mean, look, everybody's got good ideas, right? You get that feeling in your stomach, and then you go to your friends, is this a good idea? Right, right.
And then you look on Google, I'll know what he's done. If nobody tells you that it's not there for a reason. Right. But, you know, but then the hard part is actually doing it, right? Most people just don't have, you know, The gumption to go out there and actually try it and do it. I had what's been the most successful product to come out of Shark Tank So there was the thing called the comfy that Barbara Corklin did the comfy the comfy, right? That like that blanket that you wear? Oh yeah, people bought that.
It was a knock off another product just that was a snuggy. The snuggy was like a better snuggy, right? Wow. Is it better than the snuggy? I don't know. It was just more comfy. More comfy, okay.
And so the guy comes in and it's kind of like fallen apart a little bit, but they're comfortable in everything. And Barbara offers them like $50,000 for 25% of the company. And no lie, she has made just herself $37 million in Canada. Oh my God. They have sold like $400 million worth of companies.
Wow. And I say the same thing to Barbara every time I see her. Fuck you, what did I do that deal? Right, yeah. I mean, what- Barber's the best. Like, like, like, how many- how many companies do you own or have- Have- our invested in it, and even time?
Like, you know, 200 to 250. How do you keep track of them? I don't. I don't. You've got these little just- If you want to know my companies, another piece, MarkCuban.com, and you can see all of them and that literally really That's how I remember my companies I go to the website. Do you? Do you want to buy a podcast for a billion dollars?
So will I'm gonna tell you this think about it Sean wanted cash $2 million per 2% right? So that's $100 million valuation. Yes. So when we get his $100 million valuation and sell that for a billion, we'll use it to buy the podcast. There you go. Mark, when you open the paper in the morning, do you check the sports page first or the business
for it to see the stocks? Like what's the paper? Don't watch Shark Tank, but you open a paper. I know. business to see the stocks. Like what's the pay for? Don't watch Shark Tank, but you open a paper. I know. Anyway, you're getting a real good idea of what he's all about. Granddad, here spends a lot of time in slippers. No, but what's your favorite sports page?
Because sometimes people follow stocks like they fall a team. No, I do the both. So I check all the sports on Bleach and Report. And then I check, there's this Mimeo random thing that I check, just general news news and then tech meme so there's I have my websites that I go through every morning but sports first typically Yeah, because it takes two seconds just to check the score. Yeah. Yeah. Well, do you like you enjoy any other sports other than basketball? Yeah, I love I mean, I like all sports. I played rugby in college
So that literally is my my second sport, but I'm a fan of football and baseball and all that stuff. Would you ever wanna buy a team in another sport? I looked at buying the cubs, I looked at buying the pirate. Wow. They wouldn't let me buy the cubs. Why? They wouldn't let me. Major League Baseball didn't want me in. Why?
Yeah, they were afraid. Well, but what makes you an unattractive owner to Major League Baseball? All that stuff about the referees we talked about? Yeah, they don't like that. Too opinionated is too much of an old boys club. Yeah, very much so. Yeah, they literally told me no chance.
I played almost. So talk shit about him if there's no chance. Let's air it. I mean. I mean, they have their own baseballs got their own problems. I don't even need to talk shit about it Yeah, yeah, some things are so fucked up. Yeah, it speaks for itself. What about soccer? Do you see? Soccer is a is an incredible what what I call football
I'm a big premier league football. Yeah, love it love it love it. I don't yeah, right? Which team liverpool is my team. We got him. Yeah. And all right, cool it. And I love watching it. And it's growing. And it's getting even more popular in this country. And the US looks like it's going to qualify probably for the World Cup, which is great.
Just below Canada. And I don't make the scores up. And is that something that you could see that's gonna grow in this country? Yeah, soccer's growing. The biggest challenge is it's not a great TV sport. That's what I'm saying. That's what I'm saying.
Right? Yeah, see? That's what I'm saying. It's like, it's like. But I bet you could come up with a different way to shoot that sport or come up with some sort of technology to make it more interesting. No. The good thing about soccer is when you go to a game it's amazing.
Yeah. Right. It's very much experiential, kind of like hockey, right? Go into a hockey game. Yeah, but it's like they score a goal. You could run to the store and come back and it's like, oh, yeah. But there's more to it. It's a beautiful, faster than baseball.
Yeah, that's why baseball's got to it. It's the beautiful, faster than baseball. Yeah, that's why baseball's got it. I heard one time that they looked at all the major sports and they decided which ones were the best for watching on television and they're on a scale. Football was the best for the amount of plays and then breaks. Because there's only 15 minutes of football in a game. Right. You can go take a B-shit, you can get something to eat and then you can go back in the next day.
You can go back and they've done 50 replays, and they've done whatever, and it goes all the way down. And the far end is hockey, my other passion. And yeah, and I know there's a big hockey town, and I'm a big trotter, may please, Finn. Is that been working out? Actually, well, you know. Let's not get real, Mark.
And so hockey's down there, and then soccer's down there as well. So it's, it's problem is, you know, basketball, you can, basketball's problem on TV is it's 48 minutes of basketball, right? But it's great for social media because there's so many highlights and so on TikTok, on Twitter and whatever, basketball is number one. Right, and so now what's gonna happen?
Everybody, we all watch a lot of our content streaming, right? And more of a, and how did that start? Now that you know? From you. What? Yeah. So my question to you is this, now as more and more people
are shedding their cable or shedding their satellite or whatever, how is that going to? What's going to happen to live sports, do you think? What's going to change a lot? It's going to change a lot. Jason, have you ever been on TikTok? No. You don't know how to do renegade renegade Sean Sean does enough tiktok for the whole house yeah I don't really but
but you're very popular on tiktok with your kids too right you can't see I love doing this I love that I love that's much wait go back to what were you just talking about so we're talking about watching TV in the future. Yeah, it's gonna be a future of live sports. So for us, what for us? Yeah. It's gonna be more like, I love watching football. Just billionaires. Right.
No. Wait, did we, did this deal go through? Do we just sell the podcast? Oh my God, we're stocking the Donnie, this washer company. That's so interesting. I watched football now. I'm really interested. I'm really into football.
Sometimes I'll watch baseball, but it's kind of like watching this old house. It's just like, you know, I'm at the back. I feel like I always shows up. I know. Well, the new guy, Kevin. Yeah, yeah, yeah. He's great, but baseball, basketball,
you know, I went to a Lakers game once, and it's actually more thrilling to watch it live, right? When you're there, it's like, I can't when it smells like high school, and it's really cool, and it's like, right, and I'm sitting there on the sidelines, and with my straight friend Steve Shenbaum, who's so funny, and he's married.
Wait, do you say that about us, my straight friend Will and Mr. all the time? Do you really? Yeah, all the time. So then, so I'm sitting there, I'm sitting at a Lakers game. And you know when they do that, they do a lot of stadiums.
But they play that, um, kiss me. And that, it's like the kiss cam. Kiss cam, yeah. And the people like Will Smith and his wife are there. And like all these, and they catch them. And they put it on me and my straight friend Steve. And I'm looking up and I'm like, oh my God, we're bigger than the whole fucking building. And their one is the Chris and everybody's laughing. And he's panicking. And I'm looking up and I'm like, oh my God, we're bigger than the whole fucking building.
And their one is the Chris and everybody's laughing and he's panicking and I'm panicking. So I just made out with my hand. Oh boy. That's another dumb story. You were talking about your kids. Tell us, what's family life like? Is it normal?
Is it crazy? Is it, do they want to do what you do? Yeah, and do you teach them about money? And did somebody teach you about money when you were a kid? No one taught me about money. I mean, because it didn't have much, right? You just, you had to work and just do your thing. But like with my kids, obviously, my kids are 12, Jake,
15, Alyssa, and 18, Alexis. And literally Alyssa, my 15-year-old, and I watch Will and Grace, like all the time, right? That's right there. Yeah, and Ozark with Alexis. Jake, not so much. I'm sorry, but that's okay. Like I'm asking.
I'm cool. But it's scary. Check out Murderville. You got to check out Murderville. Murderville, I never really- I just downloaded it. I just downloaded it. It's fun. I'll go sit in the audience.
But now... So, they're not like young entrepreneurs already? Oh, my son Jake. Yeah. Definitely an entrepreneur. Really? Oh my God. I'm like Jake.
I was in his room two days ago. Jake, what's that candy on his little baby refrigerator there? And what do you have that candy there? He goes, oh, I sold it to my friend at school and I'm gonna make about $15. Wow. And I'm like, yeah, that's my guy. Yeah, my guy.
Did you see any crochet dinosaurs in there? Yeah, my guy. No, but no. No. Okay, so he has to work. That's the age, you know. What would you tell somebody who's starting out? I'm sorry?
Nothing. I think I know that story. I just learned about the whole sock about a year ago. I don't know what that is. You know what I'm going to go. It doesn't matter. So what would you tell? So somebody, like one of these young people
in the audience here, they're young, they've gotten out of college, they've got the first job, they've got, you know. Has nobody here? Yeah, and. And. Not true. Not true, there's that guy right there.
Number one, he said. Number one. And he's got, he's got a paycheck, he did a thing, he's got $1,000. What does he put his money into? What does he do? All right, first, you want to learn a little bit about crypto if you have a thousand dollars.
Okay. Yeah, well that's just for real. But, but, you don't want to speculate, right? So I had this conversation last night with two of my Indiana friends, right? And I don't understand using money to buy money. I don't. Yeah, do you have the real low-brown,
knuckle-dragging explanation for crypto? Yeah, right. Because I don't get it, and I'm not smart. So put aside the coin part of it, right? There's just a different way to create applications. Just like the early days of the internet, it didn't seem to make sense, right? When Amazon first came out, everybody would say, well, don't give them your credit card.
You don't know what Amazon is going to do with your credit card. You can't trust that. It was hard, and people didn't understand it. Now with crypto, there's a lot of noise, but there's different applications that you can download and buy these things called stablecoins. There's one in particular that I buy called USDC and the thing about it is you can earn more interest on that USDC stablecoin, 4% 5% depending on where you're at a little bit more and it's relatively safe, right?
It's not as safe as being in the bank because there's no FDIC insurance, but I put money there and I recommended to my friend, two of my friends here, that just made a little bit of money, you had a couple thousand dollars, that to take part of it and go to an app, voyeurgercrypto.com, whatever it may be, and put it in there and earn your 4%. But this is what I'm saying. Why are you putting, I don't understand,
you're putting your own money to buy money. It's my thing a minute. It's my thing a minute. So is it like investing in a stock market. Is that what it is? It's not really, it's more like if you were going to do currency exchanges, right? Because it's different types of currency. But because they use them to trade, they pay higher interest rates than they do in a bank.
Because you're not going to earn anything from your savings account, your checking account or whatever, right? And you might think of this as life. You think that there's one day, one day we're not going to use, because it's a lot of junk out there, right? Just like in the early days of the internet, right? There might have been 100 to one shitty companies to good companies.
Yeah, right. And because it's the early day still of crypto, it's going to take time for the nonsense, the noise and the dirt to find its way. So you would recommend, what is it? USDC. USDC over Bitcoin or something like that. Yeah, Bitcoin, like I'm glad, I'm glad you repeated that.
I almost bought a bunch of USDA steaks. Yeah, right? Yeah. Um. Mark, you've been told me to buy the steak, haven't you? I'm not earning shit. Bitcoin's kind of like, Bitcoin's kind of like digital gold, right? Yeah.
So old people buy gold and younger people are going to buy Bitcoin just because it makes more sense. You can't see it or touch or anything, but it would. So when it was the last time someone bought gold and they could touch it, right? Exactly. Because everything is so tight anyway. Yeah, yeah. And so Bitcoin is a store value and it's going to go up and down
like you see it go up and down. I like Ethereum a little bit more because it has more applications, utility. It's going to go up and down. But it's not something that I'm telling people, look, just go all in. It's like the stock market, right? Just take ten bucks. Just take ten bucks or a hundred bucks or so.
Try it, right? That's why I like Dogecoin, right? Dogecoin is silly as hell, but this is how I introduced my son to crypto, right? This is back, we opened up a Robinhood account, and I showed him he could buy Dogecoin back when it was like a penny, right? And so we spent $7 and now it's $0.15 and so you can you can buy some just to see what it's about That's interesting. And spend five bucks. Yeah, yeah, and so and then get to learn it. All right, so listen you Before I let you go because I know you got to go
You have you have a personality this huge personality which is so intoxicating and it's, you seem like such a good guy. He is, well, he's so glad to meet you. Yeah, I love it. Thank you. He seems so incredible. Fascinating. Thanks for having me on, guys.
You've been a blast. Yeah, thank you. Before you go, I want to ask you, you always seem to be, by the way, back to Shark Tank for just two seconds. You know what I love when you do? You always let people down, I love it. When people are like going on and you just raise your? You always let people down. I love it.
When people are like going on and you just raise your head, just let you go. Thank you for coming. Thank you. Thank you. That's all. Thank you. I love that.
I try to be nice, give us some advice, right? Good luck. That's what you say. Good luck, which is so like get out. So, yeah, it's just another way of saying fuck you. Yeah, I love it. I didn't say that we're all dead. I know, I know.
But I love it. So as someone who's in charge of a lot of things and a lot of business, you just seem to always be in control. Who's the one that controls you and brings you down to Earth? And is there somebody that can tell you, you don't mark shut the fuck up, you need to get real. Oh yeah, well, I wasn't kids. Yeah.
But anybody beyond your family? I'll be on my family. The raft. The rafts. Like you said. The rafts, yeah. I try to listen to every, look, look, I try to learn from everybody, you know?
So if someone's got to tell me to, like, you know, in all my businesses, there's somebody that will tell me to shut the fuck up, right? I don't mind it at all. So if I fuck up, tell me I fucked up. I don't care, right? Because. And you wanna know.
Yeah, I wanna know when I fuck up all the time. We talked about that the other day. We were talking about this idea. It's like when you're doing that, especially amongst friends, you have to have that ability to go, please let me know, because it's going to help me. And my friends are like my high school friends. I've been friends with since, you know, I've six years old.
Yeah, you've got to come up with old buddies here. Yeah, well, yeah. And so my college friends, they'll all tell me to shut the fuck up, right? And you know, they don't give up. Are they blown away? The guys that you grew up with in high school and college, or they're used to it by now, because it's been a minute that you've been really successful.
But do you guys, do you have those moments with each other where you go? Can you believe this shit all the time? Good, yeah, all the time. And look, I mean, there's not a day. Do you have the best of their money for them? No, okay. No, that's too much stress. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But there's not a day that doesn't go by where I'm just like, how the fuck this happened to me? Because seriously, yeah. We feel the same way. Yeah, right. Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, we're really good. We're really good.
Yeah, you got to. We really, we really do. We tell her all the time, we did a show the other night. We had our buddy Bradley Cooper was on our show in Brooklyn. And we were saying, we knew each other way back in the day. And he was like, this is so crazy that we get to do what we're doing in this way. It's fucking bizarre. It's insane. Yeah, we're so appreciative.
And we're not for you guys. We would not be able to say that. Yeah, I mean, some believe it will. Thank you. Mark, thank you for coming. I love you. Thank you for making it smarter. I learned stuff. I can't wait to watch more of Shark it will. Thank you. Mark, thank you for coming. I love you. Thank you for making it smarter. I learned stuff.
I can't wait to watch more of Shark Tank. I love you. Thank you for being here. Mark, we're going to be great, Mark. Thank you, everybody. Thanks, everybody. Thank you so much for having me, man. Thank you, pal.
Thank you so much for doing this. Thank you, pal. Jason, thank you so much, everybody. You have to be here. Thank you. Thank you for doing this. Thank you, everybody. Thank you so much, bud. Thank you for doing this. Thank you, thank you for doing this. Thank you, everybody. Thank you, man.
Thank you. What is Scotty? What is Scotty most commonly tell you to stop doing? What we have a wonderful, it's all dark humor. I grew up with dark, dark humor, and that's what we do. No, but what is the thing that you generally... Oh, just generally. You need to fix most.
Worrying. Worry, stop worrying. Yes. So, while also controlling, so Sean has been doing this thing the last week, and we notice every time we get in a car like to go to the airport or to go to the venue or whatever, we'll get in professional driver. Guy knows where he's going, And Sean's got his phone up.
And the guy, and he's in the back seat, and Sean goes, it's 11 minutes. And I'm like, well, there's nothing we can do about it. I know. I just like alternative routes, just in case. Anyway, so. But here's the thing. Mark Cuban is so great. I'm obsessed with Shark Tank.
He was so nice to come up. Should we pool our money a little bit? Maybe like, dude. Yeah, we should, right? Yeah, why don't we all pool our money? Yeah. Should we do like a group thing? I want to...
Also, I like the idea of you in Scotty rehearsing your Shark Tank pitch. Yes. That's what I was doing in the other room the other night when you guys were, where are you guys going? I'm like, I'll be right back. And you guys were rehearsing there. They rehearsed a little bit.
So is that, is that how the pitches go? That's campy and they're performative, right? Yes. So, but is that a prerequisite of it? I mean, can't you just come out and say, here's my idea. No, no, because they're not actors. They're not like performers.
But do you have to kind of, do they say, you got to put a little spice into it? Yeah, they do they go to show. Yeah, I will, but I don't know it yet. No, that's okay. I want to see where Scotty can we just get Scotty back out here? Scotty get back out here. Still alive.
Yeah, still alive. So wait, so again, I just want to get back to, sorry, not to get tune in the nuts and bolts of it, but so when you guys are rehearsing your bit, was Sean, was Sean Superbossy? Yeah, yeah, a little bit. He was. Yeah, a little bit.
Not gonna lie. Yeah, a little bit. I'd be like, he's got his diabetes pod. You got to get my MRI right there. Well, good bye. Yeah. What? Dad yet.
Not dad yet. And how many times did he make you rehearse it? Five or six, yeah. He's still in guess. And you guys, so you guys have been married a number of years now. Fifteen years, yeah. Did. Oh yeah.
Fifteen years. Oh, sorry, I didn't know you had in mind. No. But, did Scotty before you guys were married, did you know about the dinosaur story? Because I'm... No. No. No, but I've heard about it since. Because I'm... No. No.
No, but I've heard about it since, but not before we were married. Yeah, huh. Was that affected your... Decisions. No, this is a fair question. No, no, of course. Yeah.
So, Scotty, how did you use to masturbate? Um... Right. A lot more carefully. A lot more carefully. A lot more carefully. Not with wired figures. Mr. Bate. All right. A lot more carefully. A lot more carefully. Not with wired figures. Right.
And if somebody came in to catch you, would you say, like, don't go away? Oh, that's a bad one. Oh, my God. He's trying to do a buy. I'm trying to do a buy. He's trying to get a buy. Yeah. Well, I mean, did you ever worry when you were inside the dinosaurs mouth?
That it might somehow bite you? Bye! Thank you, Chicago! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you!
Thank you! Thank you guys! Thank you! Thank you guys! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you! Smartly crafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Granterry. It is every parent's nightmare when folding in South Jersey.
It's hard to imagine losing a loved one, a wife, a husband, a child. For many, it's their biggest fear. Amarissa Jones, host of The Vanished, a podcast that tells the stories of often overlooked and unsolved missing persons' cases. Every week, I dive into a new case, sharing the details of their mysterious disappearance, including interviews with family, friends, law enforcement, and even suspects, in an effort to reveal the truth. And I'm proud to say that this podcast has aided in a number of arrests.
It's important to me to remember the human behind the headline, and help family members find their vanished loved one, or at least a sense of peace. Follow the vanished wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad-free on Amazon Music or the Wondery app. wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad-free on Amazon Music or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.